wir schauen wir auf unseren geldbeutel
da sieht es nämlich schlechter aus drin
der teuer schock der ist schon längst da
und jetzt erwischt es die ersten mieter
eiskalt waren duschen weil man mag geht
jetzt nicht mehr ja das ist der schock
für mieter von 600 wohnungen der
wohnungsgenossenschaft dippoldiswalde
dort gibt es ein aushang schauen wir mal
rein und neben der haustür informieren
sie die mieter das warmwasser jetzt nur
zu bestimmten uhrzeit und zwar morgens
von vier bis acht mittags von 11 bis 13
uhr und abends von 17 bis 21 uhr fließt
ja wirklich irre es geht nicht darum die
mieter zu ärgern sondern sich auf das
einzustellen was wir im nächsten jahr
vielleicht sonst nicht mehr bezahlen
können so sagt es
genossenschaftsvorstand frank kühn
meißgeier ja es gehe lediglich um einen
beitrag sich ein wenig einzuschränken
wir wollen dass mieter gut durch diese
krise kommen das leben ist schon so
teuer genug sagt er
[Musik]